depuis le début de la pandémie le
conseil départemental de la vienne est
mobilisée pour vous accompagner et
apporter des réponses à la situation
le 11 mai va constituer une nouvelle
étape et de nouveaux défis
il ya la question des des masques nous
engageons à pouvoir d'ici là fournir
avec les communes l'association des
maires des masques à tous les habitants
de ce département et les questions des
tests les tests de dépistage ce jeudi
soir avec l' agence régionale de santé
le chu les laboratoires d'analysé non le
laboratoire interdépartemental callies
nous allons signer un acte de
partenariat pour pouvoir généraliser les
tests notamment aux ehpad aux résidents
et au personnel
la rentrée scolaire notamment dans les
collèges sans canne ''sera et nous
serons prêts quelle que soit le moment
décidé par le rectorat l éducation
nationale
et puis il ya continuité de l'action
publique avec évidemment la poursuite
des projets déjà engagés les chantiers
du numérique et chantier des routes le
soutien aux associations le plan collège
tout ça va continuer nous allons
imaginer avec l'ensemble des élus et
tous celles et tous ceux qui veulent y
participer à un plan de relance pour
pouvoir dès la rentrée avoir de
nouvelles actions pour le développement
d'un département que je pense aux
communes aux pro commerce de proximité
et puis il ya évidemment la question du
vieillir autrement du mieux vieillir on
veut bien que c'est un enjeu fort dans
cette crise que nous traversons nous
engageons à y travailler pour apporter
de nouvelles réponses vous être utile et
notre vocation
d'ores et déjà vous savez il ya un
guichet pour pouvoir vous orienter
répondre à votre question
n'hésitez pas à nous appeler au 05 49 55
66 27
prenez soin de vous